This video is brought to you by Wondershare Filmora 10
What's up wisecrack Michael here,
and I'm back in a heavily sanitized wisecrack studio.
Please people wear your freaking mask. Anyway,
today I've got Disney on my brain and not just because my installed sick mom
keeps sending me this photo.
And who can blame me.
They basically own or license everything I love and everything I
hate.
And that's not to mention the new season of the Mandalorian because they own
star Wars also X-Men that's right.
They own the X people and just take a Gander at the top grossing films last
year, and you'll be greeted by one name and one name only see from end game to a
Latin, from frozen to, to toy story.
Four Disney made seven of the top 10 highest grossing films of 2019.
And while this feat is impressive, even for the big mouse,
it's not exactly something new. In fact,
many of the top 50 highest grossing films of all time were either made by or
later bought by Disney. Now maybe for some of you, this doesn't matter.
As long as you get that Marvel, cinematic, goodness,
injected into your eyeballs a few times a year, and I totally get it.
But what if I told you that Disney's ever broadening artistic reach is actually
bad for culture and not just because they made the worst star war,
how let's find out in this wisecrack edition on how Disney ruined culture.
And I guess spoilers ahead for films,
you absolutely saw if you were ever a child.
But before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor.
Wondershare Filmora, we've all been picking up new hobbies since early March.
And if you're thinking about starting your own channel,
then you should check it out. Wonder sheriff will.
Maura is a simple to use video at Aiden program,
which is comparable and more affordable than other big brands.
You might know Gamora.
Isn't just for simple edits either since it includes advanced features like
Chrome McKean,
video stabilization and speed duration clipping here at wisecrack.
Until recently,
we haven't been able to shoot in our regular studio with fancy cameras in
lights, but editing with Wondershare Filmora.
We could combat some of our issues.
The new update includes some awesome key features like color match, key framing,
motion tracking, and audio ducking.
So you can create a professional looking video.
The best part is that the interface is user-friendly.
So you don't have to worry about spending too much time. Googling tutorials,
click the link in the description to check it out for yourself.
If you comment on our pin to comment,
you can win a license to get the software for free.
So let us know what you would create in Filmora.
Now back to the show in the past few decades,
Disney has gone from an industry giant to an absolute behemoth acquire.
I mean everything from the Muppets to Pixar, to Marvel,
to star Wars to most recently 21st century Fox,
of course Disney's game of hungry, hungry hippos,
but for intellectual property goes way back to the beginning.
According to the company's own telling founder,
Walt Disney moved to Los Angeles almost 800 years ago with,
and I quote a lot of hopes, but little ELLs, how wholesome four years later,
Disney got his first taste of success with Oswald. The lucky rabbit.
You only catch when Disney tried to make a, another round of these cartoons.
He found out that it distributor had gone behind his back and poached all of his
animators, worse upon reading the fine print of his contract.
Disney realized he didn't even own the rights to Oswald his distributor did.
And thus like a super villains origin story are Intrepid young waltz vows to
never get screened again. Or as disney.com puts it.
He saw to it that he owned everything that he made after that Disney set up shop
in a studio that is five minutes away from wisecrack headquarters and is now a
high-end grocery store here.
He created his most iconic character from then on Disney became a veritable
creative and financial powerhouse by 1937,
it would break all box office records with the release of snow white and the
seven dwarves early on though, the success was predicated on a simple formula,
find an existing story,
make it as cute and wholesome as possible to maximize your potential audience
and then dive into your Scrooge McDuck sized money pool.
Of course you might think this is fine.
After all pop culture is by definition entertainment aimed at the largest
possible audience. And Disney definitely had one thing and aesthetic,
you know, round faces, saucer eyes, big goofy grins.
And if the kids love it, how could it be bad? But as we've mentioned before,
Disney's reign of cuteness was not a happy accident or mere coincidence.
Walt was basically ruthless in his quest to make all things adorable.
And in the process, Disney has spent the last 100 years acquiring stories,
adapting them and ultimately twisting their original artistic intentions beyond
recognition.
All of which is to say is all this cuteness actually super unqoute,
but to see the Disney method in action, let's dissect an early example,
Pinocchio for the uninitiated. This story revolves around the titular puppet,
who just wants to be a real boy as the magical blue fairytales.
And his wish will be granted. If he proves to be brave, truthful and unselfish.
Someday, you will be a real boy.
But Pinocchio's not about that life. He runs away from home,
joins a puppet show and the lies to the blue fairy about it,
which famously leads to this.
The ferry lets them off the hook,
but Pinocchio doesn't stay out of trouble for long.
He soon whisked away on an all-expense trip to the dubiously named pleasure
Island. There Pinocchio in his resort.
Buddies engage in all sorts of vices from drinking to smoking,
to gambling only to find out that they're turning into donkeys,
but with the help of his cricket companion, Pinocchio,
narrowly escapes only to learn that his daddy got lost at sea looking for him.
It says here, he, uh, he went looking for you and, uh,
he was swallowed by a whale.
Pinocchio,
then sacrifices his little wooden life to save the old man from the literal
belly of the whale. But lo and behold, now the Pinocchio is good.
He's brought back to life by the blue fairy,
but this time as a real boy and everyone lives happily ever after if
only life was that easy. But what if I told you that the author of Pinocchio.
Carlo, Colatti never intended for his story to give children that warm,
fuzzy feeling and that once Disney had bought the rights to the story,
the company whitewash Pinocchio to fit the big mouse cutesy aesthetic.
If you have any doubt,
then I present to you the original ending of collodion Pinocchio.
Without loss of time, they tied his arms, pastor running new,
surround his throat and hung him to the branch of a tree called the big Oak.
A tempestuous northerly wind began to blow and roar angrily and
it beat the puppet from side to side,
making him swing violently like the clatter of a bell ringing for a wedding.
And the swinging gave him atrocious spasms, really bad. His breath failed.
And he could say no more shut his eyes opened his mouth,
stretched his legs and gave a long shutter and hung stiff and
insensible. You heard right?
Colotti had Pinocchio, gruesomely, hanged.
This inspired so much angry fan mail that his editor demanded.
He bring the puppet back to life and continue the series which he begrudgingly
did in Colonia. His defense though,
Pinocchio being hanged was pretty much par for the course. It's hard to say.
And Disney's version, but Pinocchio. It was intended to be a tongue in cheek,
albeit bleak morality, tale,
the simple moral be good or suffered throughout the story.
We see a mean-spirited and rude Pinocchio,
a stand in for all misbehaving children robbed starved stand,
and also his legs get sought off, but we're not supposed to feel,
especially sorry for him, his actions cause all of his suffering. Oh,
and if that wasn't enough, Colotti also heaped on the psychological abuse,
making Pinocchio at one point, think he had killed Japan and the blue fairy,
which I didn't even know as possible.
And while you and I growing up in a media diet full of high saturated Disney
cuteness might find this story. Repulsive, it's pretty run of the mill.
If you're familiar with old German folklore more recently,
we've seen similarly Gothic tones and children's books like lemony.
Snicket's a series of unfortunate events. Now let's be fair.
And maybe you don't want your kids' bedtime story ending Incruse and death,
but there's still something unsettling about the way a media giant like Disney
can take a beloved fairy tale purge it of its original intentions and thus
rewrite the narrative and our collective memories.
Instead of saying faithful to colonias artistic intention,
Disney did what it would continue to do for decades.
Bias story Belichick in a caustic VAT of cuteness and pump it out in exchange
for cold,
hard cash gone where the dark satiric overtones and in their place were syrupy
lines like this.
He deserved to be a real goer.
Pinocchio himself.
He went from being a total frat bro to the naive piece of pine.
We know and love today in the process,
his character design underwent similar changes with Walt Disney scrapping the
angular designs found in Colone story for a character model that can best be
described as what would happen. If Mickey had a baby with a tree,
obviously colonias estate was kind of with his grandson suing Disney's Italian
distributor for infringing on the moral copyright of the story.
Now I know what you're thinking. It's an adaptation.
Artists are allowed to adapt and sure they are plenty of great art exists
because someone took an existing story and made it their own.
Sometimes undercutting the original like pride and prejudice,
but at zombies more seriously,
something like there will be blood took the first few pages of Upton.
Sinclair's equally awesome book oil and basically threw away everything else,
but nobody would accuse Paul Thomas Anderson of whitewashing oil.
And I don't think pride and prejudice and zombies has somehow cheap into the
Jane Austen novel.
Maybe part of the difference lies in formula and scale PTA.
Hasn't created a billion dollar industry by stripping stories of their content
and replacing them with a deranged Daniel Day Lewis.
[Inaudible].
Disney.
On the other hand regularly take stories like Pinocchio or sleeping beauty or
hell the hunchback of Notre dam and throws them into the commercial meat
grinder. Worse.
They'd been doing this pretty consistently for the past hundred years.
Seriously. If you were to put all the Disney films on a spinning wheel,
whatever you land on would likely be an adaptation in which the original story
has been blanched artistically ground down and pumped out as a cute little
Disney sausage. Actually, why don't we just spin that wheel and find out I,
yes, the 1989 classic the little mermaid timeless story in which a young mermaid
makes a frosty and bargain with a sea witch to gain legs so she can win the hand
of a hunky brands based on the Hans Christian Andersen tale of the same name,
Disney's retelling strips.
The story of a lot of its darker and more religious overtones.
And the big mouses version were treated to a love story that ends with they
happily ever after the Prince ultimately realizes that he really digs this
mermaid. The mermaid frees herself from the sea witch's curse.
The Prince harpoons said, see which end all is basically right with the world.
The message true love saves all,
but the source material isn't nearly as happy or uplifting that's because
Anderson flatly rejected this message. First of all,
his story portrays love primarily as suffering. For example, Anderson's mermaid.
Doesn't just give away her voice and exchange for legs,
but also indoors the pain of being stabbed every time she takes a step,
nevertheless, she delights in dancing for the Prince and making him happy.
What's more in Anderson's telling the Prince never returns the mermaid's
affection. Instead he marries a local princess. So yeah,
rough deal.
But there's a reason for this Anderson wanted the mermaid to be saved,
not by love, but by sacrifice at the start of the story, the mermaid despairs,
not just because she's half fish,
but also because she doesn't have a soul and won't be able to chill with her
Prince in heaven. In fact,
the whole bargain with the which revolves around Ariel gaining a soul.
If she manages to kiss her true love. But as Anderson explained to a friend,
he never wanted the mermaid to gain a soul simply because she fell in love with
a straight up hunk. He thought such an ending would be explicitly wrong.
In short Anderson would have despised Disney's ending in which a kiss and a
strategic boat crash saves the day. See in Anderson's tale,
the mermaid saves the day with a Christ-like sacrifice where she gives up her
life and love to save the Prince. And lo and behold,
she's rewarded for her good deeds and turned into a gentle spirit.
If she helps mankind for the next 300 years, she'll be rewarded with the soul.
Her a well, according to Anderson,
this is the more natural more divine path though.
It probably wouldn't have jacked up Disney's 1989 stock prices.
And at this point we could keep rambling off examples.
The real Pocahontas is not a story about the freedom to love, who you choose.
It's about colonists kidnapping,
a native American woman and murdering her husband.
The original sleeping beauty is literally about a woman being non consensually
impregnated in her sleep and giving birth to twins.
Also in her sleep.
Now we're not going to say Disney should be making more films about assault
because that'd be horrible. However, the general Disney meat grinder,
which polishes off any roughened and savory edges comes with consequences.
In the case of Pocahontas,
it's a very easy history lesson that some people might never question,
but that's just the first of many ways that Disney's storytelling might actually
be a major disservice for developing young minds.
And that's because most of the stories Disney adapts are fairytales.
And while these stories may often be dark and complex and vaguely disturbing,
they also offer children a symbolic template for understanding the world,
for example, and at children's cancer clinic,
researchers found that patients were able to use fairytales to express and cope
with their anxieties. One child, for example, identified with the big,
bad Wolf in little red riding hood,
venting his frustration and anger by drawing an oversized Wolf with massive
teeth.
Another child drew a comically tiny Wolf as an expression of confidence and
bravery in the face of his struggles here,
we see how the darkness of fairytales can actually offer a light to children
confronting adversity,
but Disney often strips these fairytales of their bites instead inserting a
bland, wholesome narrative,
as we saw with Pinocchio and the little mermaid and ironically in the process,
Disney's developed new narratives that are in their own rights,
potentially quite destructive as psychologist,
Susan darker Smith points out young girls who identify with characters like
Cinderella or Belle from beauty and the beast are more likely to end up in
abusive relationships as adults, while interviewing victims of domestic abuse,
darker Smith found that many identified with the heroines of these stories in
which love conquers all believing that if their love is strong enough,
they can change their partner's behavior.
Of course, the reality is tragically different ironically,
by pedaling a convenient narrative in which all the world's problems can be
solved by true love.
Disney fails to give children any tools for navigating real life problems.
And that was kind of the whole point of fairytales to convey the darker and
crueler aspects of life.
So as to better prepare children for the realities of adulthood, of course,
this all begs.
The question should Disney care,
according to the legendary and incendiary free market economist,
Milton Friedman, definitely not.
He argued that companies don't have the same responsibilities that people do.
A person might have a responsibility to be a nice neighbor or recycle while a
company's only responsibility is to make more money.
And Friedman's definition of corporate responsibility has pretty much become
gospel. In other words,
Disney will only do what is required to make the most amount of money,
regardless of the social consequences.
It's the capitalist raise on debt of companies, the world over,
and it explains why Disney operates acuteness factory.
Indeed when Disney went dark in the 1970s and eighties,
it put out a series of grimmer, edgier films,
like the black cauldron that were huge box office failures,
and nearly brought about the collapse of the great empire.
The so-called Disney Renaissance of the nineties was a major course correction
back into the sentimental cuteness that has sustained the company ever since.
And it's no wonder cuteness after all has a very particular way of
hijacking or brains. And more importantly,
itself studies have shown the cuteness increases our concentration,
a useful trick to make sure humans pay close attention to their adorable young
or, you know, pay more attention to a dysfunctional snowman.
Even more telling when volunteers were hooked up to an MRI machine and bombarded
with cute images there,
nucleus accumbens also known as the pleasure center of the brain lit up and
started pumping out dopamine.
In other words, when viewers saw Mickey mouse's adorable body Bob,
up and down on screen, 100 years ago,
they were unwittingly receiving the first micro doses of Disney branded brain
candy. Interestingly enough,
the phenomenon of cuteness being used for potentially nefarious purposes has a
name, cultural theorist, Joshua Paul Dale calls it evil.
And while Dale specifically sites gambling machines that use cute cartoon
kittens. As an example,
it's not hard to argue that Disney's precious animated friends might also
qualify in the end. Cuteness is just a means for Disney to Pat its bottom line,
regardless of it's telling stories that are ultimately good for children.
And while you might not be too devastated to hear the Disney sabotage your
favorite 16th century tale about a naughty century and puppet.
Disney vacation of storytelling becomes more viscerally upsetting.
When the big mouse starts screwing around with more iconic.
Cultural works,
you catch my drift ever since Disney acquired the universe's most beloved
franchise fans have increasingly despaired at the creative choices that resulted
the last trilogy began with sentimental fan service, befitting of Disney.
It seemed to briefly flirt with darkness and complexity in the last Jedi
suggesting star Wars wouldn't fall completely into the pits of cuteness.
And then this that's right,
Disney quickly course corrected and opted for a sweet conclusion based on a
magical kiss, romantic sacrifice. And of course,
everyone you care about is Jedi royalty.
Now all of which is to say there's no property or franchise,
which Disney won't find a way to Rapids cute little tentacles around.
So what happens now? Honestly,
probably nothing good as Disney continues to grow,
which it's almost certainly going to do.
It's reasonable to worry that we'll see an expansion of their blanket philosophy
of cuteness. And as we've seen in the past,
that cuteness probably comes at the expense of story nuance and morality.
It definitely makes us nervous for the future of a franchise. Like X-Men,
it's hard to imagine Disney signing off on something that's adversive as Logan
and as Disney continues to gobble up more and more of the media we'd love.
We're worried that there won't be space for grittier darker stories for grown-up
fairytales, if you will.
But what do you guys think is our loading for the Disney empire totally
reasonable and warranted? Or do we sound like overly quarantined haters?
Let us know in the comments is always huge.
Thanks to our patrons for your support hit that subscribe button.
Like it's a fairytale you're ready to ruin four buckets of money. And as always,
thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].